[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro 2 pour mu qui
saturent les missions qui rend les
co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui on se demande s'il n'est pas
trop tard pour responsabiliser le
capitalisme pour en débattre pour en
parler votre invité eric lombard bonjour
aujourd'hui jack au directeur général de
la caisse d'aidé pour vous publier ce
livre au coeur de la finance utile à
quoi sert très panneaux édition de
l'observatoire cette île sont j'en veux
dire elle et elle est cruciale elle est
une capitale sans faire de jeu de mots
pourquoi parce que ce qu'on observe et
j'en veux dire un peu partout dans le
monde et c'est un vrai sujet c'est que
ce capitalisme sous sa forme actuelle il
crée des richesses n'y a pas débat là
dessus il ya toujours plus inégalitaire
avec des richesses des fortunes toujours
plus importante mais qui se répartissent
dans toujours moins demain et tout ça
provoque une forme de colère de rejet de
déclassement est quelque part fait
monter un petit peu le vote populiste
d'où cette question
si on ne fait rien est ce que ce
creusement des inégalités nous mène et
mène le capitalisme dans le mur je pense
que oui ça mais non seulement le
capitalisme dans le mur mais nos
sociétés ont elles été ça a été bien
analysé par des économies c'est
peut-être l'occasion de citer thomas
piketty parce que ça dépend notamment
des taux d'intérêt et nous sommes dans
une configuration depuis trente ans où
le niveau des taux d'intérêt et que ceux
qui ont un nom du capital voit ce
capital s'accumuler de façon croissante
et continue les riches toujours plus
riches et l'enrichissement ceux de
l'enrichissement se faire le patrimoine
façon par le patrimoine et ceux qui
n'ont pas de patrimoine d'abord où
beaucoup de mal à avoir un petit peu de
patrimoine et puis les rémunérations du
travail en fait augmente peu et par
rapport à la période de l'après guerre
il ya très longtemps ce qu'on appelait
les trente glorieuses les salaires
augmentaient vite et puis avait beaucoup
d'inflation les taux d'intérêt étaient
assez bas et donc en fait il y avait une
répartition qui se faisait bien entre le
travail et le capital et là les choses
se sont inversées depuis le premier choc
pétrolier ça date de 73 peut-être et
depuis ce moment là il ya un schisme qui
s'est produit et il est très mauvais
pour l' équilibre de nos sociétés parce
qu'il n'y a pas de raison objective pour
laquelle ceux qui ont un capital verrait
ce capital s'accroître et ceux qui sont
des salariés vers au niveau de vie
augmenter très modestement avec des
investisseurs qui sont et c'est votre
thèse trop gourmand en matière de
rendement avec la norme est toujours
quasiment la même depuis depuis 20 ans
les actionnaires veulent du poids 10 12
15 % de rentabilité alors que les taux
d'intérêt sont beaucoup plus bas ok pour
le coup qu'il ya qu'il ya 20 ans et donc
on se dit que cette avidité et bien là
aussi à des problématiques alors l'avait
dit et elle est aussi dans le
fonctionnement naturel du marché serre
que les entrepreneurs veulent faire
comme les autres on est dans l'économie
du benchmarking
c'est à dire qu'on se mesure aux autres
et donc si telle entreprise dans tel
secteur at-elle rentabilité les
actionnaires d'une autre vous vouloir la
même donc le mécanisme va se nourrir et
ce mécanisme en fait il a beaucoup
d'effets pervers qu'il faut absolument
intégrer si on veut corriger le
mouvement le premier effet pervers c'est
que si on demande une rentabilité trop
élevé ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas
beaucoup de projets qui sont rentables
et donc à plein de projets et donc ce
défaut glane projet qui ne se font pas
or il ya un sujet qui doit être notre
boussole aujourd'hui c'est le
réchauffement climatique et la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
à quoi bon avoir une croissance
économique si la planète n'est plus
vivable dans 30 ans et donc pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique il
faut qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'investissement de transformation notre
économie pour qu'il y ait beaucoup
d'investissements il faut donc qu'on
accepte sont assez rentable - c'est pas
assez rentable pour ya beaucoup
d'intérêts qui sont soit pas très
rentable soit risques et
transformer une usine en usine qui
n'émet plus de carbone et je dirais même
plus au lieu d'avoir une usine qui
fonctionne à partir du charbon chinois
la faire produire à partir de france
parce que ça évite le coût de transport
et ça permet d'avoir une usine
décarbonée peut-être que le produit sera
plus cher et donc l'investissement sera
moins rentable mais il va protéger la
planète et puis ensuite autres sujets
essentiels si les premiers sont plus
chères et si les ménages doivent
financer le coût pour eux de la
transition énergétique l'exemple le plus
typique c'est l'automobile passer d'une
voiture diesel à un véhicule électrique
ça coûte plus cher à l'achat acheter du
bio dont on a besoin pour lutter aussi
pour la biodiversité ça coûte plus cher
donc il faudra distribuer du pouvoir
d'achat on l'a bien vu avec les gilets
jaunes à qui d'un mouvement qui est né à
l'origine d'une question de pouvoir
d'achat pour les personnes qui prenaient
leurs voitures donc il faudra distribuer
du pouvoir d'achat il faudra investir
plus et donc pour ça il faut rétablir un
nouvel équilibre du capitalisme qui
permet d'atteindre ces deux objectifs
pouvoir d'achat et lutte contre le
réchauffement encore une fois ces
investisseurs qui demandent des
rendements déraisonnables et excessifs
comment on explique parce que j'ai une
petite tête là dessus vous dire ce que
vous en pensez mais il ya une
concurrence qui est assez féroce entre
les plaintes et les fonds de pension dos
actions les gestionnaires d'actifs qui
gère les pins des gens pour avoir
toujours plus d'argent à gérer et donc
in fine et ça aboutit à demandez donc à
des entreprises toujours plus de
rentabilité
c'est ça le noeud du problème alors il
ya une logique qui vient effectivement
celle d'investisseurs et qui est pas
forcément une logique malsaine parce que
si c'est un fonds de pension qui vient
de tel ou tel pays et qui va s'occuper
de la retraite de ces fonctionnaires de
ses enseignants c'est très légitime de
gérer la retraite des gens et donc ils
vont demander à un rendement important
et il me semble que la contrepartie ça
doit être aussi l'attitude des
dirigeants d'entreprises de même qu'ils
aient un moment doit faire des choix
responsables
il ya quelque chose que je trouve très
encourageant dans l'évolution du
capitalisme c'est que les jeunes
entrepreneurs aujourd'hui d'abord
contrairement à ce qui se passait il ya
dix ans c'est plus des nouveaux projets
de startups sur le web cd vrai projet
industriel ancré dans nos territoires et
dans la construction de leur projet
industriel souvent et 10 moi je veux que
celle heures minimum soit plus élevé je
veux qu'on ait un contrat social qui
soit plus généreux que le contrat social
français qui est déjà même s'il peut
paraître insuffisant plus généraux dans
beaucoup d'autres pays donc il ya des
entrepreneurs qui intègrent dans leurs
projets ça ce sont les nouvelles
entreprises mais eh oui ou d'entreprises
qui veulent se dégager de la rentabilité
eh bien il n'y a pas cinquante solutions
il faut comprimer les salaires il faut
délocaliser dans des pays où les coûts
salariaux sont plus faibles il faut
moins investir et encore une fois la ja
un cercle pernicieux qui aboutit à un
rejet par les populations de ce système
capitaliste alors ça doit être la
responsabilité de tous les acteurs les
investisseurs et la caisse des dépôts
comme investisseur est très attentive à
ce que les sociétés dans lesquelles nous
investissons
respecte un minimum de contrat social
c'est à dire que la politique sociale de
l'entreprise doit être vertueuse et le
plus impossible évidemment la politique
environnementale doit s'inscrire dans la
trajectoire des accords de paris et donc
les investisseurs doivent être
responsables et je pense que les chefs
d'entreprise ou une responsabilité dans
ce sens le chêne l'entreprise henri
seigneur qui a la responsabilité pour
ces chefs d'entreprise l'actionnaire il
apporte du capital la société fixe des
règles et salariés apportent leur force
de travail mais celui qui assure
l'équilibré tout ça c'est le chef
d'entreprise je pense que le chef
d'entreprise doit être en situation et
ceux qui sont vertébrés qui ont par
ailleurs l'autorité pour le faire
peuvent dire à leurs actionnaires vous
me demander d'aller trop loin moi je
souhaite que cette entreprise est
meilleure contribution à l'intérêt
général et est aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'on voit beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprises le font en réalité
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise intègre
cette dimension je vais vous donner un
exemple alors sans faire de publicité un
grand groupe financier dans lequel j'ai
travaillé basé en france dont le patron
a décidé à un moment donné la banque
d'un monde qui change que le contrat
social qui s'appliquait en france
appliquerait à tous les salariés
européens
j'étais très fier à ce moment là faire
partie de ce groupe parce que ça c'était
quelque chose qui garantit un équilibre
de tous les collaborateurs en europe au
delà du contrat social de tel ou tel
pays et s'étaient payés par
l'actionnaire à la fin bien sûr est-ce
qu'il faut pas aussi comme chercher à
contraindre contrat mais inciter les
actionnaires pour le coup au delà du
chef d'entreprise être moins gourmand
accepter un rendement dans important
parce que le monde a changé parce
qu'elle doit intéressons se sont
beaucoup plus bas et là je me dis je
vois pas les fonds de pension se
réveille un matin comme ça anglo saxons
en disant maintien spontanément on va
changer notre exigence de rendement ça
viendra pas comme ça par magie alors
c'est toute la question est
effectivement dans ce livre je développe
ça mais j'ai pas de réponse tout de
suite il ya déjà une réponse qui me
paraît pas la bonne c'est la réponse
fiscale c'est à dire que ce n'est pas en
taxant plus le capital par hypothèse
d'une façon ou d'une autre que l'on va
régler le sujet parce qu'au contraire là
on alourdit le coût du capital je pense
que c'est plutôt de
delà du ressort d'une forme de consensus
économique qui doit être un consensus
nouveau qui a fonctionné encore une fois
dans les trente glorieuses on était dans
la reconstruction après la guerre je
pense qu'il faut qu'il ya un consensus
pour que dans notamment la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique des
investisseurs
et les entrepreneurs se mettent d'accord
sur un nouveau modèle et on a on a des
amorces de cela la caisse des partis de
groupements internationaux qui fédère
les grands investisseurs pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique et on
se dit tout ce que nous devons
décarbonés nos participations et inciter
les entreprises dans lesquelles nous
investissons à se mettre dans la
trajectoire des accords de paris à 25
degrés en 2050 et à côté de cela et de
façon à mon avis convergentes on doit
aussi avoir un mandat social que nous
donnons à ces entreprises d'avoir un
meilleur répartition qui d'ailleurs ne
serait pas forcément que par le salaire
ça peut se faire aussi par la
participation au capital oui bien sûr il
ya salariés il est bien sûr ouais après
je reviens encore de façon les
actionnaires est ce qu'on pourrait pas
s'inspirer je sais pas de ce qui se fait
bon c'est un peu loin vous dirais le
canada ou plus proche de nous les pays
nordiques où on voit des des retraites
qui sont gérés par des fonds de pension
qui n'exige pas ses rendements excessif
sur le sur le capital à partir du moment
que ça permet de payer les retraites
c'est pas quelque chose qui pourrait
nous inspirer ça alors la question des
fonds de pension est une question dont
je crains qu'elle se pose que très
marginalement en france parce que nous
n'avons pas de fonds de pension
élection après élection les électeurs
renouvellent leur souhait de maintenir
un système de retraite par répartition
éclat une pension publics qu'ils soient
publics ou privés un fonds de pension ça
veut dire que vous devez accumuler du
capital pendant une certaine période
pour à prépayer la rente est donc
c'était assez intelligent de le faire au
sortir de la deuxième guerre mondiale
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est des milliards
des centaines de milliards qui sont
détenus par les futurs retraités de ces
pays là en france on n'a pas pris ce
train leur marche même si on a le fonds
de réserve des retraites que j'ai
l'honneur de présider et qui joue ce
rôle mais qui est un petit acteur par
rapport à leurs concurrents néerlandais
ou anglais par exemple eric lombard
jamais qu'on revienne aussi sûr il ya
d'autres tares pardon du capitalisme il
ya cette extrême financiarisation et ça
choque beaucoup de gens évidemment il ya
cet usage excessif de la dette du levier
d'endettement c'est normal taux
d'intérêt on est très bas pendant
pendant des années on a évoqué cette
exigence relativement élevé du capital
ce rendement et puis aussi les rachats
d'actions par les entreprises on en
parlera après c'est un peu technique
mais on dit que voilà le capitalisme il
s'est déréglé sadis fonctionne
aujourd'hui le constat on le partage
après il ya les solutions on en parlera
après mais il ya quelque chose qui ne
qui cloche pardon jours alors l'origine
de ce dérèglement et si vous prenez le
dernier livre de patrick artus il
explique très bien de façon très
pédagogique
c'est la crise de 2008 et l'océan de
liquidités qui ont été déversées par les
banques centrales pour lutter contre
cette fille mais c'est ce qui a évité
malgré sion et un chaos financier à
lorient il fallait il faut pas avoir ce
regret puisque c'est comme quand les
pompiers arrosent d'une maison qui est
en feu le feu est éteint mais après la
maison et les gorgés d'humidité sacré
les effets sont liés sacré des effets
secondaires qui sont regrettables mais
moins pire que si la maison avait brûlé
totalement donc donc en fait la banque
centrale européenne à arroser le marché
de liquidités maintenant ces liquidités
en fait complètement perturber les
équilibres financiers de la planète
puisque les taux d'intérêt à très court
terme sont même négatif toujours en
europe qui sont devenus positifs aux
états unis et les taux d'intérêt à long
terme sont à des niveaux qui n'ont pas
de sens économique qu'ils étaient encore
négatif aussi c'était aussi pour
financer et scénaristique il en passant
par dont on a bradé alors qu'ici ils
l'ont fait aussi pour favoriser les
investissements fait en réalité ça n'a
pas eu l'effet escompté parce que au
lieu d'investir plus les acteurs ont
demandé une rentabilité plus importante
et donc cette perturbation très grandes
de l'univers de taux d'intérêts et de
liquidité et l'origine de ces
déplacements et donc donc la fois de
meyrals même si elle n'est pas leur
faute et leurs responsabilités ils ont
raison de le faire maintenant il faut
reprendre cette liquidités surabondantes
ce qu'ils ont commencé à faire à pas
comptés c'est très compliqué de sortir
de ces situations là des on voit que les
états unis sont à la limite de la
récession on verra comment ça se
développe dans les mois il entra parce
qu'il ya ces traits en dlc groupe
mondial les terreaux salle mais ça sera
un des éléments de la solution de
revenir à une structure de taux
d'intérêt plus normale entre guillemets
et qui permettra aussi de désinciter cet
excès de rentabilité du capital qui est
la conséquence de cela excède
rentabilité du capital eric lombard et
qui est obtenu par un mécanisme pardon
on va s'arrêter deux mondes là dessus de
rachat d'actions qui pour moi est le
summum de la bizarrerie pourquoi parce
que il faut expliquer un petit peu
beaucoup là qu'ils aient quasiment
toutes les entreprises cotées
aujourd'hui rachètent leurs propres
titres en circulation souvent d'ailleurs
au prix de l'endettement s'endettant ce
qui est quand même encore une couche
supérieure la bizarrerie est les rachète
pour les annuler et donc pour
mécaniquement faire monter
artificiellement
la rentabilité le le cours boursier et
là on se dit voilà en gros c'est le
gâteau reste le même le gâteau c'est les
profits mais il ya moins de diamants une
part c'est exactement ça c'est pas le
summum de la bizarrerie économique et
l'importance est une pratique est
largement répandue aujourd'hui aux états
unis si en france c'est la conséquence
de ce dont on parle c'est à dire que ces
entreprises qui recherchent par exemple
une rentabilité nette de 8% après impôt
voit un projet qui rapportent du 6% mais
plutôt que d'aller vers ce projet 6% qui
peut être très vertueux et puis aussi et
remplir des besoins des consommateurs
c'est aussi ça les projets eh bien ils
rendent l'argent aux actionnaires en
disant je trouve pas de projet à 8 et
donc le fait que l'on recherche cette
rentabilité trop élevé ce capitaine
sanofi quelque part c'est trop c'est une
sorte d' atrophie et l'atrophié elle est
aussi dans la répartition du capital
parce que un monde où la richesse et
concentrés par quelques dizaines de
personnes mais quelle est l'utilité de
cette concentration de richesses en
quelques mains et c'est pas un discours
politiquement engagé que je tiens même
si peut-être il ya un peu de ça derrière
c'est que c'est une question réaliste si
la richesse n'est pas bien répartie
l'effet économique nuls parce que c'est
là j'en suis là aujourd'hui c'est la
concerne est d'accord sur le constat
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant encore
une fois un capitation qui se réforme ça
passe par quoi et ses acquis de réformer
ce qui va se réformer tout seul ou est
ce que c'est le rôle du politique alors
les responsables politiques je pense
peuvent simplifier des éléments qui
bénéficie aux salariés alors il ya déjà
des mécanismes qui existent la
participation l'intéressement
le fait de faire rentrer les salariés au
capital des entreprises et donc
eux-mêmes d'être associé à cette
création de richesse des mécanismes
positif défendent ailier de distribution
d'actions gratuites pour les salariés
qui deviennent actionnaires est donc
parti pendant dès qu'ils peuvent
s'enrichir à mesure que l'entreprise
s'enrichit elle même mais bien sûr parce
que la réalité c'est que le meilleur
placement qu'on peut faire sur le
malaise est pas là dessus hein
écoutez vous demanderez à geoffroy roux
de bézieux ou à d'autres je ne suis pas
sûr parce que par ailleurs ça a un côté
très pédagogique mais si on dit que le
meilleur placement qu'on puisse faire
c'est d'acheter des actions coton mais
dans une vision de très long terme c'est
qu'il trouvait sur le long terme et
éprouvée sur le nombre derniers russ
meyer père me préparer sa retraite le
mieux c'est chaque année d'acheter
quelques actions et au bout d'un temps
ça ça constitue un patrimoine donc aider
les salariés à se constituer une
participation dans leur entreprise
qu'ils connaissent dans laquelle ils
travaillent tous les jours ces vertueux
et ça participe delà du partage des
richesses certains disent qu'on cumule
le risque risque à la fois des salariés
loris que ce soit trop important et il
faut une actionnaire de l'année entre
absolument vous avez raison il faut
veiller à ce que la quote-part du
patrimoine que ça représente pour chaque
salarié reste
raisonnable on pourrait aussi changer
les règles par exemple sur les fonts
vous avez peut-être vu récemment que des
actionnaires qui ont vendu des
participations ou décidé de partager une
partie du produit de la vente avec les
salariés il ya une affaire importante ou
la plus-value était de 700 millions
d'euros donc ces massifs et le vendeur a
décidé de reverser 70 millions d'euros
aux salariés d'ailleurs il bute sur le
fait qu'il n'y a pas de mécanisme
juridique qui permet de faire simplement
donc ça on peut peut-être y travailler
pour que les fonds d'investissement
c'est assez rare
oui mais c'est pas que c'est assez rare
je pense c'est la première fois qu'on le
voit là mais admettons que ce soit non
pas rares mais précurseur il faut
peut-être trouver des systèmes pour
encourager cela et les fonds
d'investissement qui dégageait revenus
extrêmement importants souvent par de la
bonne gestion il faut pas non plus jeter
le bébé avec l'eau du bain mais si le
produit de ces investissements peut être
mieux partagée tout le monde y gagne ce
qu'il faut bien voir aussi des salariés
mieux rémunérés ça va soutenir la
consommation et donc il faut des gens
des salaires aussi qu'un sujet
d'ailleurs alors il ya un sujet bas
salaires avec une difficulté la fois que
je me suis exprimé là-dessus à
représentants d'entreprises m'a dit oui
mais il ya des entreprises qui sont dans
des situations de compétition tellement
difficile qu'elles ne peuvent pas le
faire donc dans ces cas là il faut
évidemment privilégié la rentabilité des
entreprises pour que l'entreprise
subsistent parce que si la conséquence
de cela c'est que des entreprises
ferment portes c'est qu'on aura mal
travaillé mais évidemment pour des
entreprises qui ont les moyens il faut
augmenter les bas salaires et d'ailleurs
les je vous parlais de nouveaux
entrepreneurs qui s'installe les
salaires minimums sont au dessus du smic
et quand c'est possible naturellement il
faut le faire avoir des salariés dans
les conseils d'administration carrément
vous dit pourquoi pas pour qu'ils
participent finalement il ya une
cogestion qui ne participe un peu comme
en allemagne à la à la stratégie aux
décisions stratégiques des entreprises
pour que ce soit lorsqu'on sensuelle ça
se fait dans les grandes entreprises ça
soit la caisse des dépôts nous avons
deux salariés qui sont à la commission
de surveillance et par une concentration
un homme une femme et et dont la
participation est extrêmement féconde
parce que non seulement d'abord ils ont
un jugement éclairé sur les projets qui
sont portés en plus ils peuvent aussi
dire aux autres membres de la commission
qu'est ce qui se passe dans
l'institution et donc dans mes fonctions
précédent dans le privé il y avait des
salariés dans les conseils je trouve ça
apporte beaucoup et que c'est aussi une
façon d'apaiser la relation qui à mon
avis doivent être une relation de
coopération entre les salariés et
l'équipe de direction quelle place pour
eric lombard pour pour le rôle des
banques publiques justement dans cette
réforme du capitalisme est-ce qu'il faut
revenir à des banques publiques
commercial alors où on est en france
dans l'économie mixte donc nos grandes
banques sont soient cotées en bourse
soit mutualiste toi d'ailleurs souvent
les deux et puis nous avons des grandes
banques publiques comme bpi france où ce
film fait partie aussi groupe caisse des
dépôts qui sont des bancs publics ou la
banque postale qui fait partie d'un
groupe public moi je pense que cette
mixité elle est féconde d'abord ce qu'on
voit bien c'est qu'il ya pas de modèle
qui soit supérieur ou un autre il ya des
banques mutualistes des banques privées
ou des bancs publics qui sont efficaces
et c'est très bien ainsi et puis chacune
chacun a un mandat particulier puis
france a un mandat de soutien de
l'économie de développement notamment
des entreprises qui naissent les autres
banques sont moins investie en fonds
propres et donc que tous à mon avis
permet de résoudre des solutions un peu
un peu différent et ce cas la caisse
vous vous retrouvez à financer des
projets ou des besoins que les banques
commerciales au quotidien de financement
parce que on revient au sujet de départ
parce que pas assez rentable alors nous
avons décidé à la caisse des dépôts que
l'activité qui est placé sous la marque
banques des territoires dirigée par
olivier sichel aurait un coût du capital
très inférieur au marché on est autour
de 3 ou 4% donc ça vous suffit du quad
eu 4 % ça suffit pour financer un projet
à mener même si la star de la caisse aux
assurés pour la caisse si le projet est
une utilité sociale forte même moi je
suis prêt ce qu'on descende à 2 ou 3%
parce que l'utilité sociale c'est quand
même très important et quand je dis
utilité sociale c'est au sens large
c'est aussi la contribution à la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
donc c'est le notaire chez vous
d'ailleurs ça financer cette transition
énergétique pour laquelle tout n'est pas
rentable encore une fois nous on a
décidé qu'il n'y a pas un euro qui doit
être investi ci contribuent pas à la
lutte contre le réchauffement il ya que
quand on fait un logement social il faut
aussi que le logement social soit bien
isolée de façon à ce que il n'ya pas
d'émission en effet de serre quand on
finance une entreprise il faut qu'elle
ait un plan de respect des accords de
paris donc c'est évidemment une priorité
absolue et je mets d'ailleurs avec la
lutte contre le réchauffement la lutte
pour la biodiversité les deux combats et
en étant lié avoir parlé de la finance
verte et de la finance responsable un
petit bout d'un reproche qu'on fait
souvent marchés financiers d'ailleurs
même le fmi qui sont pas des
bolchéviques long le long admis on
reproche souvent marchés financiers
d'être déconnecté de des réalités
économiques
on l'a vu au long de la pandémie on l'a
vu au moment du delà de la guerre en
ukraine avec des bourses qui avait des
parts chuté mais qui rapidement avaient
retrouvé leur clos effacé leurs pertes
c'est un mauvais procès ou où là encore
une fois il ya une espèce de
dysfonctionnement c'est leur façon de
réagir la vision que j'ai des marchés
financiers sur lesquels je travaille
surtout depuis assez longtemps c'est que
c'est en réalité un bon thermomètre de
ce que c'est censé mesurer c'est à dire
qu'après ça dépend sur quel marché vous
êtes mais le marché des vraies
situations les marchés les marchés
actions représentent ce que le marché
estime être la valeur d'une entreprise
donc ça n'est pas prédictifs mais en
revanche dans la durée ça représente
bien la capacité bénéficiaire de
l'entreprise son insertion dans la
compétition internationale frauciel des
niveaux stratosphériques de valorisation
qui sont déconnectés peut-être aussi des
fondamentaux la réalité quand j'ai envie
de vous donner un exemple amazon on a
longtemps dit quand amazon perdait de
l'argent année après année que c'était
une folie qu amazon va autant d'argent
et bien les gens qui ont investi dans
amazon à ce moment là ils sont sûrs
exemple parce que la promesse de
développement et de transformation a été
rempli par le management et cette
entreprise vaut aujourd'hui encore plus
d'argent c'est un elle travaille le plus
rapide soit dit en passant par dont ce
n'est pas le gars ça le plus rentable
non mais en fait qu'est ce que regardent
le marché il regarde la perspective de
résultat est là dessus on sait on
connaît le fonctionnement des analystes
qui regardent sans grand détail y
compris avec qui l'on préfère de la
région de logique que année si derrière
après ça marche ça n'a pas d'importance
puisque il se projette dans la durée
donc je trouve au contraire que
l'indication donnée par le marché à un
moment donné est toujours très utile
parce que c'est une synthèse en fait on
est une équipe d'une maison marché même
s'il n'est pas tous les jours raison
c'est un peu la daj en fait dans une
économie ouverte plus ou moins libéral
le prix est un très bon indicateur c'est
un très bon élément d'information et qui
après d'ailleurs entraîne tout le reste
donc le prix d'une entreprise ça lui
permet à près de se refinancer de même
qu' il ya quelque chose d'intéressant
récemment le prix de l'énergie
augmentent dans la période on voit bien
et prend on va voir augmenter
durablement et bien tout ce qui est
isolé à sion thermique des bâtiments a
fait un bond ces derniers mois de façon
considérable dans les hlm dans les
bâtiments publics dans les bâtiments
privés parce que les gens disent à
l'énergie va coûter plus cher donc je
vais essayer d'en consommer moins je
m'isole donc le prix reste un marqueur
important dans nos économies pour finir
sur une note positive eric lambin qu'on
parle de la finance verte qui financent
il ya beaucoup d'argent qui se déverse
et c'est très bien pour financer des
entreprises de la transition énergétique
des entreprises qui ont un impact
positif encore une fois sur sur leur
environnement sur leurs salariés leurs
parties prenantes est ce que cette
finance vers téléguidé par des ambitions
humaniste écologique ou est ce que c'est
juste parce que c'est lucratif encore
une fois voilà quelle est votre position
là dessus en même temps j'avais dit au
peuple si on peut marier écologie et
bénéfices on a envie d'applaudir aussi
bas il faut dire que un entrepreneur il
prend un risque et met son patrimoine en
jeu donc il faut absolument qu'il en
tire en tout cas un revenu après il ya
des entrepreneurs qui décide moi je
préfère une rentabilité plus faible que
d'autres et si je suis utile il ya même
des entrepreneurs associatif qui ne tire
aucun revenu ou presque de leurs
activités et donc il ya toute une part
de la finance qui est financée
d'ailleurs par des fonds
d'investissement ou des épargnants se
disent moi je préfère être moins
rémunérés et est dans des projets qui
ont une dimension sociale plus
importantes mais on peut aussi viser une
rentabilité de marché tout en ayant des
projets qui sont utiles aujourd'hui les
champs d'éoliennes les panneaux solaires
les énergies renouvelables sont des
projets qui donnent des rentabilité
satisfaisante et qui sont indispensables
malgré tout donc à nouveau cette
diversité d'intention des opérateurs me
paraît une richesse qu'il faut préserver
sans dire il ya des bons il ya des
mauvaises c'est plus complexe que ça bon
donc il n'est pas trop tard pour
responsabiliser le capitalisme même si
on se dit qu'il ya urgence il ya une
ambiance en prise de conscience il ya
urgence et cette prise de conscience et
merci beaucoup david jacquot me permet
de l'exprimer il faut qu'elle s'étende
parce que encore une fois en matière de
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
on n'est pas dans la bonne dans le bon
rythme il faut qu'on aille beaucoup plus
vite voilà à lire au coeur de la finance
utile à quoi sert votre épargne signé
eric lombard aux édition de
l'observatoire merci d'arrêter avec nous
merci david jacquot voilà c'est la fin
de pourvu que ça dure les missions qui
rend les co-responsables magazine à
revoir sur public sénat il ya du replay
bien sûr sur publicsenat.fr rendez vous
dans deux semaines
[Musique]
et